Alright guys, so here is a brand new chapter of the course and in this chapter I'm going
to be talking about the session highs, lows and SMT.
So the SMT that occurs at the highs and lows of the sessions are extremely powerful and
by keeping that in mind, we can frame our trades whenever a setup is presented to us.
So I'm looking at NAS100 and US30 because both of them are correlating assets.
You can similarly look at your USD, GBP, USD, AUD, USD, NZD, USD, AUD, JPY and NZD, JPY
and your JPY and GBP, JPY, right?
So you can also look at S&P 500 but I'm looking at NAS100 and US30, right?
You can look NAS100, US30 and S&P 500, three of them at once to look for the setup.
So I'm going to mark out the high of the Asia session and low of the Asia session on NAS100
and similarly I'm going to mark out the high of the Asian session.
This is the high right here and low of the Asia session, right?
So what do you notice here?
The very first thing that you see.
So on NAS100, we failed to take out the Asia low but on US30, on the fifth, so the time
firm is very important.
We have to stick to this time firm but on US30, we took out the Asia low, right?
So notice this low here and notice this low here.
We have SMT divergence.
So you have to trade the one that did not sweep the liquidity.
Why?
Because this is a stronger pair, right?
The reason why NAS100 failed to take out this low is because the bullish momentum on NAS100
is stronger but on US30, it is weaker because we drop down and we took out liquidity, right?
Now you can trade both of them but you primarily want to trade the one that did not sweep liquidity
because it is showing bullish momentum.
Now there are two ways to look for your entry.
The number one and easiest way is to look for change in the state of delivery and what
is changed in the state of delivery.
So whenever a candle closes above a bearish autoblock, so this is a bullish autoblock,
so I'm going to rephrase what I said, whenever a candle closes above a bullish autoblock,
so this is a bullish autoblock, right?
It's not bearish, so I am rephrasing what I said.
So this is a bearish autoblock.
We have SMT here, right?
Price closes above the body of this bullish autoblock and that is called change in the
state of delivery.
Another way to look at it is the SMT candle, so this candle, right?
This candle right here caused SMT, right?
So you can also look for a closure above that candle and that is also considered a change
in the state of delivery.
However, primarily you want to wait for price to close above the bullish autoblock that
is marked out around here.
Now that is your change in the state of delivery and you can take your entry, right?
Or if you go to the old ways, we can simply look for a market structure shift and from
the autoblock and you can see how price went right up.
Okay, so the key thing to note here is that the SMT is occurring at the lows and highs
of the session.
So as you can see on US steady, we took out the low, but on NAS100, we failed to take
out the low.
So this shows that there was a clear manipulation to the downside, so liquidity on US steady,
but since the NAS100 was a stronger asset, it didn't suit liquidity and that's giving
us a clue that, okay, now price will push to the upside.
So your first target could be the Asia high, right?
If you go back to the Asian session strategy from course one, you will know that if the
low is taken, we take target high, if the high is taken, we target low.
So the number one reason why you would have lost your Asian session strategy trade is
because there could have been an SMT here and when price swept the Asia high and you
look for a market structure shift and it didn't work out, you were like, okay, this
strategy didn't work today, but in reality, we took out the low on another correlating
asset or pair.
I hope that makes sense.
So let me give you guys a couple more examples.
All right, so what can you see in this picture, right?
Pause the video and see what happened in the London session, right?
So it's very clear guys, very, very clear.
You have your Asia, sorry, London high here, right, and you have your London high here.
Now on NAS100, we took out the London high, right?
It's very clear.
We took out the London high with this candle over here.
Notice this, right?
Now we want to look at the same candle and you can see we failed to take out the London
high on US 30.
Now we are simply waiting for change in the state of delivery.
Now once that happens, you can see price went back tapped into this autoblock once again.
Push the price down, right, right away with extreme momentum.
We took out London low and then you could have probably trailed your stop loss or you could
have just went for one to two or one to three Richard Ward.
But remember, you're always going to break even after one to one Richard Ward is hit
because that keeps us safe from losing streaks.
Because remember this, no matter what strategy you try, no matter what model you trade, even
if ICT comes to you and teaches you a strategy personally, you are going to have losing streaks.
So three trades in a row, four trades in a row, right?
The key here is to protect your capital.
That is the most important thing.
So that is why we call break even, all right, offer one to one or in rare cases when your
bias is strong and the auto flow is in alignment with your, with your high timeframe, you
know, trend, then you can simply go break even after one to one point five are.
Some people also take a partial at one to one point five because you do not want to
take a trade, wait for an entire day and then close that break even.
So it would be best if you take a partial, you know, there's not, there's not any
strategy risk management strategy that is best.
There are different ways to approach risk management.
And I personally believe that going break even at one to one and then taking your profit
at one to two is the best approach.
Let me give you guys more examples.
All right, guys.
So in this example, you can see that we have the London high here and London high here.
So London high was taken out on US 30, but on that's 100, it didn't take out.
So this is the SMT candle.
This candle caused SMT, right?
So we want to refer back to it.
And you can see right here, when candle closes, Floyd, I consider this an SMT divergence, right?
And what happens afterwards?
Look, we also had inverse for what you have to do.
So you could have probably inverse it as well.
But entry on the retest stops below, right?
So your first target would have been the London low.
And then you can see price just went down like crazily.
Okay.
So we do not look at the New York session because we do not want to be treating the PM
session, but this is the model.
Now make sure that if you want to increase your win rate, you are aligned with the high
time from trend, which would be the four hour trend, right?
So if we are bearish, you are only looking for longs.
If we are, if we are sorry, if you are bearish, you are only looking for shots.
If you are bullish, you are only looking for longs.
It's very simple.
Refer back to the old videos where I explain auto flow, but that would be it.
So let's move on to the next chapter now.